- Well, you say the secret
to playing a good villain
is great eye contact, right?
- Mm-hmm.
- I think you're really good at it
'cause I've seen your stuff,
and I'm like, you're really good at it.
But it's interesting
who sits on this couch,
see, it's terrifying. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Wait, like... (laughs)
So that's on "The Mandalorian."
Look at, you just elevator eyed me.
No, no, so wait, so the
funny thing is though
that people sit on this couch,
it's interesting to see the
people that can't do it.
They break eye contact
and I don't know why,
but it's interesting.
I love eye contact.
- You know, the eyes are
the window into the soul.
And sometimes we don't
want people to see us
especially when we're in an awkward
and uncomfortable moment.
But my life is awkward and uncomfortable.
The camera's in front
of my face every day.
I've gotta do emotional things
that I don't normally do every moment.
And I have to get somehow
comfortable with it
and have it be all right.
And so the best way to be
calm, (breathes in heavily)
my yoga practice helped me with-
- Breathing is so important.
- "Breaking Bad."
Breathing really helped.
You know, how do I exude
being powerful, being calm,
being relaxed?
I breathe and it helps me a great deal,
and I make eye contact.
- I love eye contact. I
love connecting with people.
I love showing all my faults.
And I love all of it
'cause I think that we can learn
and we all have those like,
so like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, we all aren't perfect,
so I think it's great to share that.